nasser et et m'a dit le journaliste
franco-iranien pour rfi nasser et m a
dit bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
sur la matinale de weert et france alors
sur quoi précisément doivent se mettre
d'accord américains et européens
aujourd'hui sur le dossier iranien
écoutez tout et dans un sens c'est déjà
dit la rencontre d'aujourd'hui sert
surtout à rots tisser les liens entre
les quatre pays signataires ocidentaux
de l'accord nucléaire avec téhéran
mise à mal par l'ancien président
américain donald tromper à définir une
stratégie commune pour freiner à nouveau
de la marche accélérée de teyran vers la
capacité de produire la bombe nucléaire
même si côté occidental comme je viens
de le signaler
tout est déjà dit sur l'orientation à
adopter face à teyran à savoir
renégocier l'accord devenue caduque
pour les occidentaux après les retraits
successifs des américains et des
iraniens en y incluant la discussion sur
les mici et les agissements des
stabilisateurs de l'iran dans la région
or la sphère est loin d'être simple est
ce que l'arrivée de youtube hayden
apaise vraiment les relations est ce que
dans les faits lire on peut espérer
quelque chose
écoutez officiellement terran s'oppose à
toute nouvelle négociation sur l'accord
signe en 2015 qu'on a demandé non
seulement dubaï mais ses alliés en
europe 1 d'après les iraniens leur
programme de missiles balistiques et
leurs agissements dans la région ne sont
pas négociables même si l'or est à
l'apaisement mais réellement les
iraniens toute fraction confondues
modéré ou pas n'ont pas finalement
d'autre option que de trouver un modus
vivendi
un terrain d'entente avec les
occidentaux car leurs économies et
exemple enough
indéfiniment se payer le luxe d'avoir
les sanctions qui les étouffe
économiquement on risque d'avoir à
l'arrivée on révolte des affamés et de
vous voir leur système fragilisé sous le
coup des sanctions américain s'effondrer
comme un château de cartes
sur les yeux pour être quoi comme
terrain d'entente il est difficile à le
définir il ya plusieurs hypothèses mais
toujours est il que on l'a toujours pas
trouvé ce terrain d'entende et parle
mesure provoque provocatrice que les
iraniens près il est de plus en plus
difficile de trouver ce mot douce vivant
dit or ils mettent par leurs mesures
provocatrices les occidentaux devant ce
dilemme ou bien nous aurons là bon ou
bien vous serez obligés de nous
bombarder pour nous empêcher d'en avoir
et comme les iraniens sont persuadés
jusqu'à maintenant qu'ils ne seront pas
bombarder ils ne cesseront pas de violer
l'accord nucléaire pour inverser le
rapport de force en leur faveur en vous
de faire lever les sanctions américains
contre elle au pétrole et le système
bancaire iranien or toujours est-il en
gros le kvk lancé donald rond dans la
mare en se retirant de l'accord
nucléaire avec téhéran en mai 2018
continue à faire des grosses vagues et
les démarches iranien risque de se
retourner contre aux quarts finalement
ça pour avoir l'air doux fuite en avant
effectivement vous parler de cette
pression que l'iran met en enrichissant
de l'uranium dans des quantités plus
importantes que prévu par un accord on
le rappelle cette stratégie elle va pas
être payante pour vous il va tout
dépendant fait des rapports de force
tout dépend en fait de la manière dont
les discussions s'ils en amont
vont avoir lieu si ces quatre pays
occidentaux à commencer par la nouvelle
administration américains disent do sol
voire qu'ils veulent sauver l'accord
signé en 2015 avec l'iran pour
l'empêcher de fabriquer la bombe
nucléaire
ils disent en même temps que cet accord
est devenu insuffisant est quasiment
inexistant et qu' il faut même y ajouter
des clauses aujourd'hui pour discuter
le programme des missiles balistiques et
le comportement des stabilisateurs de
l'iran dans la région en y incluant
maintenant dans la liste en la nouvelle
discussion israël et les pays arabes du
golfe et persie qui sont les plus
inquiété par ses agissements par le
programme nucléaire et des missiles
balistiques de téhéran
chose que finalement j'ai du mal à
croire que les iraniens puissent
accepter en fait facilement même si
l'administration byden lève
partiellement les sanctions c'est à dire
même si l'administration byden ce prix
finalement de son seul moyen de pression
sur l'iran au risque de se faire passer
pour un faible face au chantage du
régime iranien
affaibli et inquiet de sol à venir et
face notamment à la chine et à la russie
avec qui à peine arrivé au pouvoir du
rpt by day est entré en bras de fer donc
le dossier iranien
c'est un des dossiers majeurs de
l'administration américaine sur la sur
la scène internationale les dossiers
chinois et russes même dans un sens sont
plus importants et on sait bien que joe
by day n'aura qu'un seul mandat
donc il va peut-être délégué en partie
au moins pour le moment la discussion
avec les iraniens à ses alliés européens
peut-être même à la france mais rien ne
dit que on aura à l'arrivée un résultat
satisfaisant donc tout à prévoir en fait
merci beaucoup et nasser et m a dit pour
votre éclairage le rappelle vous êtes
journaliste franco iranien pour r
puis ce